when Dark Elves threaten all of
existence keep a cool head remember your
training and team up with the guy who
tried to eradicate mankind in the
Avengers these are apparently the
writings of the Asgardian handbook for
the dark world so Thor the dark world is
the sequel to Thor it's also a sequel to
the Avengers and it's all inter woven at
this point it's another Marvel movie and
we're all pumped that it exists and in
Thor the dark world it's after the
Avengers Loki's all imprisoned in Asgard
first this wise awesome badass really
cool and collected leader that all the
realms want to get behind and like yeah
that guy now the Dark Elves are like
we've come back to just cover everything
in darkness for Dark Elves what else
would they be doing usually elves are
hippies not these guys they are dicks
not Thor is reunited with Natalie
Portman now they're gonna stay the day
together now this is a Thor movie for
the people who didn't really
particularly care for the first Thor
movie or at least enjoyed the first Thor
movie but they were like Thor wasn't
Thor for a lot of the movie and I wanted
to see Thor do more Thor things now you
see Thor do a lot of Thor things because
he's Thor for the entire movies not
learning a lesson or anything he's not
mortal no he is an awesome god he has
his hammer that he throws and flies with
he's taking on dark elves he can't be a
normal human fleshy dude and do that
[ __ ] and for the most part the movies
really enjoyable I mean you got you have
God's fighting Dark Elves what makes
this movie let's face it
Loki's a big part of that Tom Hiddleston
is Loki just should be in every Marvel
movie ever Loki is like Marvel's answer
to the Joker but he's not quite a joker
ripoff he just pulls it off he's fun to
watch he always has a scheme you don't
know if you can trust the guy you really
shouldn't trust the guy but he's there
and let's face it I like the character
of Thor Thor in this movie I really like
he's like he's like Superman Thor in
this movie risks everything his
reputation his girlfriend he risks it
all to save lives gotta admit when
Superman was getting smacked through
buildings he didn't exactly do that more
is like Superman super mega he's like
he's so good I like heroes that are like
that if they're not made to be boring
and Thor's just not boring to me because
he learned his lesson in the first one
and the end of this movie is awesome
when it's all just it's coming to a head
and everything is going down Thor's
fighting dudes you swinging the hammers
I am that was my mom hammer and you know
you saw it when the fights going down I
can only describe it as portal to meets
mortal kombat the end of this movie is
portal combat and I got no complaints
about that but the road leading up to it
I gotta admit it's kind of like you okay
it's classic good guy bad guy stuff with
gods nothing really got me going the
movie has a lot of humor and I thought
about Iron Man 3 and that Iron Man 3 had
a lot of humor it seems like these
Avengers phase 2 movies have more humor
than the Avengers phase 1 movies I don't
know if they're doing that on purpose
but it just it is a thing and I laughed
when the humor hit when the movies done
you're reflecting on it you're like they
should have cut back the humor in some
part some of you look at the Avengers
the Avengers had a lot of humor in it
but when the [ __ ] was going downs like
the movie news like okay let's now's not
the time for humor let's get real but it
doesn't change the fact that Thor the
dark world still enjoyable it's really
cool the end was awesome and you know I
liked the first Thor movie and I gotta
say I liked the first Thor movie more
than I liked Thor the dark world
I liked the premise of the first Thor
movie the main complaint that people had
with it was actually what I liked about
it I like the fact that Thor lost all of
his power and he spent the entire movie
trying to prove himself and become the
man he needs to be so when he does
you're like yeah you earned it reminded
me a God of War 2 and Kratos lost all of
his powers like all right now let's
retain the power we saw Thor as a God
who fell and he had to become a God
again by the end of this movie and
undeniably kicks ass so I will say I
would by Thor the dark world on blu-ray
this movie doesn't have a fake villains
you know Marvel movies learn from the
past Marvel movies so Thor the dark
world have you seen it what do you
prefer Thor or Thor the dark world these
are the relevant decisions you're gonna
have to make folks if you want your
right of passage into adulthood
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you